[Music]
hi I'm Jolene and this is like a
property investor
[Music]
welcome back to Sunderland and the
renovation is complete families our food
bucket let's go have a look go to-- this
is the dining room
this just looks really really fresh
that's all the walls are being painted
brilliant white I move the skirting
bloss brilliant white floor must new
vinyl flooring
sorry laminate flooring which looks
fantastic and the family so Cheryl and
their four children love it which is
superb news give them a nice place to go
out and take over the world so this is
brilliant so yeah this is the darling
room next door is probably the piece of
resistance and it's the kitchen so you
probably remember before really old and
rickety quite here the cupboard doors
are falling off so I think this door
here was fell off in my hands there's
now nice and fresh retiled new lights
which they think are superb it had come
with a bit of drama in here because all
the floor under the bathroom underneath
the bar was rotten from probably wet
bath for being making and then just down
here on the floor all of this was
absolute and the woodworm but it wasn't
just wood one they obviously knew about
it then they
Cowboys up the job just put our new
boards
so as we self dug deeper and you'll see
on the foot than on the photos it was
absolutely shot to pieces so we had to
redo all the flooring out to here and
then we treat like they're Patsy's at
woodworm elsewhere in the house so we
treated all the floorboards replaced
three or four of the joists a bit of
extra work but yeah we got that which is
good I think having a sitting tenant and
the full house refurb definitely puts
the pressure on so when there's a bit of
a delay to begin with with the solicitor
for a week when you got a family who's
moved out that put the pressure on and
then dealing with all the woodworm and
all the rotten floor and things that put
an extra week on to the once the refurb
so in total we did the refurb in five
weeks which is some going really because
we literally replastered the whole thing
and up with all the extra issues we
found made sure it's all safe and yeah I
think well you'll find out later but I
think Cheryl has been over the moon with
it so which is great so just for
hollinger Brendan is the we replace this
door so this door you sphere sorry a
uPVC door being replaced in silas store
a storeroom
it's just being done out with the
flooring and they're not done out with
the bench as in the kitchen so all looks
one continuous house which is great
in the kitchen we kept all the units
pretty much as they were
we removed the one that was on the wall
here and we moved the washing machine
from the utility down into the corner so
that's now far part of the kitchen we've
put in a nice new electric oven and
electric hob there's gas before with the
lighting
it's obviously done down lighters so
we've got new plaster board and then put
the holes in that and came down through
almost looks superb there's a slight
damp issue a lot of damp issues sorry we
have a leak from the bath so the rubber
fails where they've put in the new bath
on one of the fittings so that has
leaked twice but they're coming back
just what the leaks now being fixed and
they'll be back in the next week just a
stained block it and then repaint it so
it's just like a little stacking issue
really very about I think that's about
three slacking issues that you'll see as
we go around I'm just thinking issue
number one so nice new different rooms
that we used to have the beam when all
the way around halfway up the wall
that's all been replaced lights before
we're up here so you can image out the
UM the shade so the wide thing but
further down and that's thing issue
number two Soviet electricians coming
back to put those new lights on the
fireplace is being removed so the hearth
came out into the floor by about 50
centimetres so that's now completely
gone now a beautiful living room all the
color scheme has sort of made it so that
you've got a nice charcoal gray gray
Gray's whites and blacks which fits in
with Cheryl's want taking up all the
pictures and things just superb so the
bathrooms have been well before you
probably remember had a horrible plastic
laminate
that's what being removed will now put
my stars around the bath brand-new valve
[Applause]
brand-new shower you think new toilet
towel roll is hiding behind the door we
obviously had the issue with the the
rubber are leaking from the tap so that
went downstairs but that's all being
rectified now the last family bathroom
so we asked before to have the laminate
floor for a while so we've just got the
carpet on the stairs and in bedroom
number two the master bedroom we put
vinyl down in the bathroom just in case
there's leaks and things and what we
found with experience is that sometimes
if there's a leak on laminate the
flooring bubbles so therefore vinyls
probably better in the bathroom two of
the bedrooms have been beautifully
kitted out the third bedroom we're going
to rubbish I was going to replace the
beds for the boys so that's not being
done quite yet but well have a look so
beautiful white all over the place
really really fresh windows all now
working gaskets have been replaced so
it's good insulation I think if you look
around it's just feels big and spacious
which is fantastic news the wardrobes
actually there's a some before I think
we got footage of it we'd left the
wardrobes in here because we decided if
we moved them out to storage they break
well they broke anyway so I'm having to
get three new wardrobes just while
they're there from there IKEA and they
just don't move particularly well so
it's just manpower required to put this
back together nice and fresh
the master bedroom so there's a hole in
the wall just down here which has been
there's a hole anglers a hole up here
which has been plastered over there's a
hole down here which is being vented I'm
good no chimney breasts and it's much
better having air circulating to avoid
dump to new wardrobes on the side and
then all the furnitures back in so now
feels big and spacious and good stacking
issue number three is on the windows
while on the central window the unit
needs to be replaced because
condensation formed on the inside so we
just literally have the glazier come
back in so I'll be fitted in the next
week I'm so that will be done but that's
gone to the boys bedroom we talked about
potentially moving the door so that it
opened onto the opposite side but the
stairs come out to alter here say the
UCR diagonal piece going up I learned
long and we decide the best about a box
here so the lads can put their toys and
things on top and if you got a box here
there's really no point in having the
door open the opposite way because
you're still going to be blocked um so
we've left the door as is we spent a
light switch you could stay in the same
place we've now got this nice new unit
which you can use to put things on top
of and then just behind on the window
you can see the unit again needs for
replacing because it's got a
consultation but once we put the new
beds in this room will look pretty good
and provide drugs whether a nice room
bedroom for the next 10 years pronounced
or work just at the front and the water
pipes being fixed where when the washing
up is done all the water's going out
into the driveway so now going straight
down the pipe and down the drain as it
should of course I was just outside
there's been a fair few jobs done so the
verges on the top of the roof they've
all been filled in so there won't be any
draft going in it anymore
a couple of tiles were missing from the
roof so they've been replaced the arch
on top of the roof missing so that's
been think
the Woodworks all being furnished or
looks nice and you know the guttering
there's an old black paintball it's
brown bear being painted black and was
peeling so all the gut strings being
replaced there's now nice and white and
then finally just to tidy it all up the
other side of the house that being
painted which looks great cool just
looking at the front of the house so the
doors been replaced so before it's quite
wobbly because there's no central
support so that's been put in there's
glass going all the way from top to
bottom which they didn't like so that's
being replaced the guttering on the
front arch was the black agains ice
cream a place to be white all the wood
works been varnished and the Front's
being painted and water is no longer
going all over the front drive but the
gutter the pipes are all now connected
and not broken so it's looking good last
but not least is the patio door I'll
have to be rehung so that now hangs
nicely so water doesn't get in and it
closes properly it's a swarm of cheese
here okay tidy and just feel comfortable
a lot got everybody around visiting i've
been inviting everybody absolute it's so
nice studying about it and I know before
you said
in their friends around No
well they've been on and on I was asleep
but I've told them no until it's
finished and then they're all having a
little sleep all the little things call
so the ends of the project and I think
the talent Cheryl is really really happy
with the end result which is superb I
think having a setting tunnel it does
come with its own challenges but it's
probably quite read you have assessing
talent and then needs to a full refurb
so we'll just otherwise that when you
when the opportunity presents itself
again I think doing a refurb you never
quite know what you're getting into
because absolutely found here when we
took some of the floorboards back we
found the one on the bathroom is Ross
and there's woodworm throughout quite a
few mice too hard to get rid of that
issue so there's always that to contend
with the timescales because you never
know quite what you're getting into
you always come up with a slight plan so
four weeks was our guesstimate which is
actually quite accurate and it would
have been four weeks if it hadn't have
been for the solicitor which there's
pretty much nothing you can do we can do
is nicely get on that back just for a
solicitor is brilliant so it's just
working out the vendors solicitor oh and
again it's not worth upsetting them
because if you upset them they'll just
go fur personally slow so it's just or
keeping them onside but making sure they
get the right paperwork coming for you
and then yeah a week for getting rid of
all the all the wood Berman things but I
think in any property that you move into
you probably need to allow a bit of
fudge factor time for
I think having a nice tenant is a
definite well definitely definitely
helps because they understand and if
you're completely sure that your end
products you've got complete confidence
that they're going to get a really nice
house it helps your bargaining or it
gives you more credit in your bargaining
bank because you can say yes you know
they may go through hardship which you
would do if you're moving out of your
place for a month but when they move
back in as you just saw they're moving
into a brand new house very special so
yet probably holiday and things weren't
quite what they would have been hung
because up we're so going through the
refurb process so making sure [ __ ] was
still done but overall definitely
definitely not put me off and on to the
on to the next one
you